never notice what we hear has a huge
impact on her movie going experience and
sound editors create and prepare all
sound elements for eventual mixing not
too different from what a musician does
which is something I know you are and
you're just as brilliant as being a
singer as an actor Thank You ASA the
only difference is that these guys get
nominated for Oscars for it here are the
nominees for achievement in sound
editing baby driver
Julian Slater Blade Runner 2049 mark
Angie and Fiorina dunker Richard King
and Alex Gibson
the shape of water Nathan Robitaille and
Nelson Ferrara
starwars the last Jedi Matthew wood and
Ren Kleiss nd Oscar goes to Dunkirk
Richard King
[Applause]
nomination for
women sixth nomination for Richard King
he previously took home Oscars in this
category for inception the Dark Knight
and Master and Commander the far side of
the world
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you look to thank the Academy to
my awesome crew and Burbank all my
friends and colleagues at Warner
Brothers Chris and Emma wherever you are
thank you for including me in this
amazing trip it was an amazing film
about an amazing event thank you and all
my love to my wife Sue and my son Sam
and thank them for thank you for putting
up with me prattling on about Stuka
sirens for months hello I'd like to
thank the Academy for including me in
this nomination it's historic and I
think music editors and I are very
grateful and that's it yes I'm done